okay i'm not done with this rant i'm not
done part four of if you get pregnant
it's your own fault
ladies
will always say it's all about education
what education
do you need
i don't understand
did you not know
did you not know that
when you have sex
a kid can be made
oh no i knew well what what education
did you not know that there's birth
control oh no i knew
did you not know what condoms were and
then
let's dive into the education what
education want education for sex and
schools you want you want a teacher you
want a strange older person okay
teaching
my children
about sex oh no
i i was a volleyball player i had some
creepy ass coaches i can't even imagine
how creepy sex ed teachers are i can't
okay look at
we're gonna give strangers
like if you were a predator what would
be the best position
to go for
okay
and and it goes back to the real
question
why
what education do you need most stable
adults and even teenagers no
condoms birth control iuds there's like
a million options
so if you get pregnant
no it wasn't a lack of education it was
your poor decision making
that's it and if i get pregnant someday
on accident that's what i'll tell you it
was my own fault
but
but see
ladies it's not that hard if you get
pregnant it's your own fault it's not
the guy's fault it's yours
that's it that's my rant i'm done